hi there today we're looking at
reinforcement learning with unsupervised
auxiliary tasks by Google so in this
paper the author's consider a
reinforcement learning task and I can
show you what it looks like it looks
like this kind of a maze or this is an
example that they give where you have to
navigate the maze it's 3d and you have
to navigate from pixel inputs you have
to collect apples and reach the goal and
this gives you rewards so on the left
you can see what the agents actually see
on the right you can see it from a
top-down view the problem is of course
that the input is very or the reward is
very sparse meaning that you have to
navigate a lot of maze before you even
get a single point
so reinforcement learning has a big
trouble with this because it relies on
constant reward to notice what actions
are good and what actions are bad so the
author's proposes in addition to the
regular loss and that you would have so
your reward which is this thing you
would also have an additional set of
auxiliary tasks and here C goes over the
observe observe you control tasks that
you specify
each of those has a reward and you're
also trying to maximize these each with
with some kind of a weight here and the
thing is that the parameters that you
maximize over control all of the
different tasks so they are partly
shared between the tasks so what you're
hoping is that by kind of learning to do
one thing you also learn to do another
thing so the difference between this and
let's say you might have so we've seen
kind of work of it like this before
where you do it in more like an
autoencoder setting so for example you
can't agencies the input on the left
here and it kind of tries to predict
what the next in
but we'll be what the next frame will be
developed behind this is if you can
accurately predict what the next frame
will be maybe it learned something
useful about the environment in this
work it's different because now we
couple a reward to these tasks and I can
show you here what the authors propose
as additional rewards sorry they're
further on top let me go there
especially they considered here these
two auxiliary control tasks so pixel
changes which means that the agent
actually tries to actively change pixels
so it gets a reward for changing the
pixels in the input so it tries to
maximize this it needs to learn what do
I need to do to maximize my pixel
changes and probably that will be moving
around so we will learn to kind of move
around not move against the wall because
if it moves against the wall the pixels
pixels won't change so it will kind of
learn to move along the the like how a
regular human agent would also move
speak not into a wall not like into a
dead end or something such that the
pixels always change of course it's not
perfect you can also change your pixels
quite a bit by simply spinning around in
a circle but this is one of the early
tasks that they are meant the agent with
the other one is Network features so
it's kind of a meta learning here you
actually reward the agent for changing
its own internal activations so the hope
is that it kind of learns about
something about itself how can i
activate my internal neural network
units and it gets rewarded for that so
we might want to activate a lot of them
and want to learn how they're activated
so this kind of self introspection you
also hope that it kind of leads to a
network
does more sophisticated tasks or that by
nature of trying to get most pixel pixel
changes and the most network feature
activated
that you also learn something useful for
the actual task um so these are the two
tasks they propose in addition they also
do and they have a drawing this over
here they also do a lot of other things
namely on the top left you can kind of
see here that what's a database agent
this is an a3 see agent meaning that
it's an it's an active critic so you
learn a policy and you learn a value
network we might go over this in a
future video school just consider this a
standard reinforcement learning agent
you feed its experience into a replay
buffer and out of the replay buffer you
do many things so for one you try to
learn these auxiliary tasks note that
these are shared parameters between all
these networks that's why I do daily
tasks actually help you also try to
better learn your value function and
they call this off policy learning
because you kind of pause the reciting
training for a while and then you train
the value function some more just
because that helps you also try a reward
prediction in here and the way they do
it as I explained is kind of in a skewed
sampling way so how do all the
situation's you can be in the agent will
have a reward
very very few times so what they do is
they simply sample out of the replay
buffer out of all the experiences they
had so far they sample more frequently
the experiences where they actually
gotten a reward that way that the whole
is of course the agent if you if you
look at when you can zoom in here if you
look at the the experience here where
you actually get an apple and the agent
might learn a lot faster or there's some
kind of Apple there and I move towards
get a reward so that's the the hope that
you instantly recognize high reward
situations and kanda are not so
interested in non reward situations of
course it doesn't reduce bias in your
sampling and you might decide for
yourself if that's good or bad here it
seems to work so there's a lot of
experiments in this task and labyrinth
tasks and they of course as with
research they read state of the art
they're much better than anything else
no I mean they don't boast as much so
it's actually a fair comparisons the
criticisms so they also evaluate a motor
against the criticisms that I have are
twofold first of all the choice of
ability tasks is completely up to the
implementer which means that I have to
decide as an implementer of this
algorithm
what my Tillery tasks will be and here
pixel changes and Network features they
seem like fairly general tasks that you
could apply to a lot of these kind of
problems but it always kind of comes
down to how much knowledge about the
task would you like to go into the into
the actor and here I mean you can see it
makes sense to get at least the pixel
changes as an auxiliary task but it's
questionable how much of kind of domain
knowledge this already encodes so the
fact the choice of these are certainly
something that you have to decide as a
human and I think these are these are
good choices so they're not too domain
specific but also they do correspond to
like some
visual moving around game tasks and the
other um kind of criticisms not really
criticism is just a remark is that they
do a lot of a lot of things so I mean
the paper is about the auxiliary tasks
but they also then do these skimmed
sampling and the policy value learning
and so on and of course you can kind of
argue yeah this is all done you know the
reinforcement learning tasks that's why
it's a fair comparison I guess it's a
philosophical question if you want to
reach state of the art of course you
have to first of all get a better a
better method here this would be the
auxiliary tasks this is the new idea and
then implement all the tricks that the
the other people have discovered which
is good because you kind of reach the
highest performance you can get but also
the problem is you make it harder to
compare you make it harder to see where
the improvement is coming from have you
simply chosen better high parameters for
the reward predictions of things have
you simply is there any interactions
maybe between the auxiliary tasks and
dispute sampling part all these kind of
things wash out and it's not really
clear where the improvement is coming
from on the other hand if you simply
take a basic basic basic algorithm like
just a three see here on the top left
and you augment it with nothing but
these are the early tasks the bottom
left then and then you see an
improvement you can be relatively sure
it's due to your new idea but of course
you won't reach any state-of-the-art
numbers because everyone that does a3
see also does these tricks philosophical
question Here I am standing more on the
side of not doing the tricks or maybe
doing both yeah decide for yourself and
have a nice day